Kung Fu Panda fans the fourth
installment is on its way but what does
this mean for the Beloved franchise is
this the start of a new Trilogy will
there be new villains is po still the
Kung Fu Panda don't worry we've got all
the details about Kung Fu Panda 4 if you
saw Kung Fu Panda 3 and were surprised
to hear that a fourth installment was
coming you're not alone the franchise's
first three films made for a perfect
complete Trilogy so many fans think that
the new movie will be the first of
another Trilogy the minds behind the
franchise haven't confirmed or denied
this Theory but in director Mike
Mitchell's own words quote it's very
possible so while as of now we can't be
100% certain that Kung Fu Panda 4 will
be the first in a three movie Arc it's
still clear that Mitchell is confident
in the direction he's taking the
franchise we wanted to make sure that we
going to tell the next step for po we
had the best story and the best villain
and the best theme to move forward so
it's clear that this franchise is in
good hands and as such Mitchell isn't
losing sight of what makes Kung Fu Panda
what it is in an interview with next
best picture he explained quote I don't
think anyone will ever get tired of
seeing Jack Black as this Panda yeah
that's something we can all agree on oh
man oh Panda oh this is so cool Mitchell
says he just is this Panda he comes up
with all these scoes and all the Shasha
buoys and
stuff yeah it wouldn't be Kung Fu Panda
without Jack Black as Po and in
Mitchell's words we could watch him
forever that said we have made the most
epic chapter of this franchise here
we're all happy that PO will be
returning but some new characters are
joining the cast as well and with them
will come even more star power thanks to
the trailer we know that Viola Davis
will be playing chameleon a villain who
can transform into anyone she meets one
once I possess the Kung Fu of every
Master villain no one will dare question
my power and it's clear that this is
going to be one iconic character she's a
small chameleon right but but she has so
much within her Davis just just killed
it with that everything everywhere all
at once star kou Kuan also joins the
cast as Han a Pangolin who becomes Po's
friend during his citybound quest and
Mike Mitchell has teased that the there
will be many more new faces introduced
in this new installment not the least of
which is Zen the fox joins po to help
him in his journey Zen will be played by
Aquafina and is clearly a complex
character you sound surprised is it
surprising yet despite her sorted past
it seems that PO is still on Zen's side
in fact some fans have theorized that
Zen could be the future Dragon Warrior
if so this could be the focus of the
franchise's new Trilogy Of course while
the new characters and cast members are
exciting The Familiar Faces who will be
returning are just as vital to making
this installment the best the franchise
has seen of course Jack Black is back as
po keep your surf off my Turf Master
Shifu played by Dustin Hoffman will be
back as well only do what you can do you
will never be more than you are now yes
it'll be good to see these two reunited
if you missed Mr ping don't worry James
Hong will be back as Po's father we need
a fourth and there are some actors and
characters who are returning who may
surprise you like Ian mcshain were
prising his role from the original Kung
Fu Panda tyong did I scare him off while
seeing taong return after so long is
certainly a surprise the minds behind
the movie were excited to make it happen
once we found our story and it like we
knew that it was like hey we want to
bring back villains from the past if
you're rejoicing right about now because
you've been a long time tyong fan then
you might be happy to hear that Mike
Mitchell is right there with you I think
he's the best villain that this studio
has ever created we officially can't
wait to see all these characters on the
big screen but we're going to have to
wait until March 8th so why has there
been such a big delay after all despite
a few foray onto the small screen we
haven't seen a Kung Fu Panda film since
2016 interestingly Kung Fu Panda 4 was
actually announced in 2022 so if you've
been waiting since then then you're
probably extra excited to see this new
installment first a shakeup at
Dreamworks Animation in 2016 stalled
production then there was some confusion
regarding whether the franchise should
go on Kung Fu Panda 3 director Jennifer
Yu Nelson spoke about her belief that
the franchise should be a Trilogy in
2018 luckily a great script defied the
odds and we'll be able to see the newest
film come spring are you ready for Kung
Fu Panda 4 would you rather see a new
trilogy or a continuation of the
franchise we're used to let's discuss in
the comments and for more videos about
your animated favorites like And
subscribe to the
things